let me ask
uh it's a fun thing to make a
world-class roboticist
engineer and leader uncomfortable with a
ridiculous question about
life what is the meaning of life dmitry
from a robotics and a human perspective
you only have a couple minutes or one
minute to answer so
i don't know if that makes it more
difficult or easier actually yeah
you know they're very tempted to
uh quote uh one of the stories
stories by uh uh isaac asimov actually
um actually titled appropriately titled
the last question
uh short story where you know the plot
is that
uh you know humans build this super
computer you know this this ai
intelligence
and you know once it's get power gets
powerful enough they pose this question
to it you know
how can the entropy in the universe be
reduced all right so
your computer replies hang as of yet
insufficient information to give a
meaningful answer
right and then you know thousands of
years go by and they keep posing the
same question and the computer you know
it gets more and more powerful and keeps
giving the same answer yeah as of yet
insufficient information to give a
meaningful answer or something along
those lines
right and then you know keeps you know
happening
and happening you fast forward like
millions of years into the future and
you know billions of years and like at
some point it's just the only entity in
the universe
it's like absorbed all humanity and all
knowledge in the universe and it like
keeps posing the same question to itself
and you know
uh finally it gets to the point where it
is able to answer that question but of
course at that point you know there's
you know the heat death of the universe
has occurred and that's the only entity
and there's nobody else to provide that
answer to so the only thing it can do is
to
you know answer it by demonstration so
it like you know recreates the
big bang right and resets the clock
right
uh but you know uh i i can try to give
kind of a a a different version
of the answer you know maybe uh not on
the behalf of all humanity i think that
that might be a little presumptuous for
me to speak about the meaning of life on
the behalf of all humans but at least
you know personally
uh it changes right i think if you think
about kind of what
uh gives uh
you know you and uh your life meaning
and purpose and kind of what drives you
um uh it seems to
change over time right and the the the
lifespan
of you know kind of your existence uh
you know when
just when you just enter this this world
right it's all about kind of new
experiences right you get like new
smells
new sounds new emotions right and
like that's what's driving you right
you're experiencing new
amazing things right and that that's
magical right that's pretty pretty
pretty pretty awesome right that gives
you kind of meaning
then you get a little bit older you
start more intentionally
uh learning about things right i guess
actually before you start intentionally
learning probably fun
fun is a thing that gives you kind of
meaning and purpose and purpose and the
thing you optimize for right
and like fun is good uh then you get you
know start learning and i guess that
this this
uh joy of comprehension
and discovery is another thing that you
know gives you
meaning and purpose and drives you right
then you know you
learn enough stuff and it you want to
give some of it back right so
impact and contributions back to you
know technology or society
people you know local or more globally
is becomes a new thing that you know
drives a lot of kind of your behavior
and is something that gives you purpose
and
that you derive you know positive
feedback from right
you know then you go and so on and so
forth you go through various stages of
life i
i if you have if you
have kids like that definitely changes
your perspective on things you know i
have three
that definitely flips some bits in your
head in terms of
you know what you care about and what
you optimize for and you know what
matters what doesn't matter right
so you know and so on and so forth right
and i i i it seems
to me that you know it's all of those
things and as
you kind of you go through life um
you know you want these to be additive
right
new experiences fun learning
impact like you want you want to you
know be accumulating you know i don't
want to
you know stop having fun or experiencing
new things and i think it's important
that
it just kind of becomes uh additive as
opposed to a replacement or subtraction
but yeah
those views probably as far as i got but
you know ask me in a few years i might
have one or two more to add to the list
and before you know it time is up just
like it is for this conversation
but hopefully it was a fun ride it was a
huge honor to meet you as i as you know
i've been
a fan of yours and a fan of google
self-driving car and waymo for a long
time
i can't wait i mean it's one of the most
exciting if we look back in the 21st
century i truly believe it'll be one of
the most exciting things we
descendants of apes have created on this
earth so
i'm a huge fan and i can't wait to see
what you do
next thanks so much for talking today
thanks thanks for having me and it's a
also a huge fan doesn't work honestly
and i really enjoyed it thank you
you